die fdp war der ansicht dass die
beschlussfähigkeit des parlaments
hergestellt werden müsse ist aber und
auch das können wir bei dieser
gelegenheit ihm noch mal zeigen bislang
noch nicht wieder zurückgekehrt
in das parlament wir könnten mal auch
einen blick auf die türen werfen auch
wieder den einen oder anderen aus den
reihen der afg schon identifizieren
können das ist nicht ganz klar warum die
fdp-abgeordneten bislang noch nicht
wieder reingekommen sind denn es dürfte
eigentlich genauso klar sein dass auch
die afg abgeordneten doch für die
überweisung auch ihres antrages in den
ausschuss in diesem fall für bildung und
forschung gehen sollten damit er da
beziehungsweise das was darin festgelegt
ist auch in diesem ausschuss weiter
besprochen wird gut ist so müssen wir
jetzt wissen wir jetzt mal gerade so in
kauf nehmen die tagesordnung verschiebt
sich ich glaube im moment haben wir
schon versucht von mindestens einer
guten halben stunde das nächste thema
das hier besprochen werden wird wenn es
einmal so weit ist ist die
buchpreisbindung da können wir
eigentlich schon einen blick drauf
werfen während hier nach wie vor die
abgeordneten damit beschäftigt sind in
den plenarsaal zurückgekehrt wie gesagt
mit ausnahme der afg abgeordnete die
sich noch nicht wieder auf den weg ins
plenum gemacht haben dauert es eben
alles ein bisschen länger hier kann man
nix machen
eine große mehrheit das hat die
bundestagsvizepräsidentin pau auch schon
gesagt ist das sieht sie natürlich weil
sie gegenüber diesen beiden türen sitzt
durch die die abgeordneten jetzt wieder
reinkommen eine übergroße mehrheit wird
hier
zeigen oder in der richtung abstimmen
dass diese vier anträge um die es in der
letzten stunde ja gegangen ist dann auch
tatsächlich in die ausschüsse überwiesen
werden aber naja er schließlich die
brisanz dieses vorgangs im moment nicht
ehrlich gesagt nicht wirklich auch die
weiteren punkte die hier heute noch auf
der tagesordnung stehen sind anträge die
überwiesen werden anträge der von
einzelnen fraktionen kein gesetz kein
gesetzentwurf mehr so wie das heute
morgen war
da könnte man ja eine beschlussfähigkeit
unter umständen mehr in zweifel ziehen
aber nun gut
nun ist es parlamentarisch möglich man
kann davon gebrauch machen und das ist
in diesem fall auch geschehen können wir
mal gucken was sich auf der
regierungsbank zwischenzeitlich so tut
da mit peter altmaier schon gesehen der
auch wieder dreist direkt vor uns steht
der bundesgesundheitsminister hier
entspannen das können sie wiederum nicht
sehen aber er steht direkt hier vor
unserer sprecherkabine und unterhält
sich und nutzte die zeit für den einen
und anderen plausch auch der vorsitzende
der unionsfraktion geht nochmal durch
seine reihen das plenum ist jetzt
natürlich erheblich besser besetzt als
das heute morgen oder vor dieser
abstimmung der fall gewesen ist weil
jetzt halt außer den fachpolitikern
denen die sich hauptsächlich mit den
themen die hier besprochen werden auch
alle abgeordneten da sind ja so ist die
lage
wir gucken wie gesagt und schon
angekündigt auf dem nächsten
tagesordnungspunkt 1 oder gibt es sogar
schon ergebnis
muss ich mal gerade gucken es ist gerade
was es nach vorne getragen worden zum
präsidium dann sich auch
bundestagspräsident schäuble ist wieder
in den plenarsaal zurückgekommen spricht
im moment mit petra pau der
vize-präsidentin und ich das richtig
sehe steht vor den türen niemand mehr
muss man gucken ob die kollegen dass wir
uns anfangen können
es sind alle die da gewesen sind oder um
die es hier eigentlich geht sind wieder
drin und wir stellen fest
die fdp fraktion hat sich dieser
abstimmung über die beschlussfähigkeit
des parlaments als auch der überweisung
der anträge zum thema
wissenschaftsstandort deutschland jetzt
offensichtlich entzogen
auch da erschließt sich mir der tiefere
sinn dieser maßnahme im moment noch
nicht vielleicht kriegen wir aufschluss
auf die eine oder andere weise aber wir
sehen hier nur besetzt die fraktionen
aus linken spd grünen union und fdp
petra bauer hat jetzt noch mal versucht
zu klären ob noch irgendwelche
abgeordneten daran gehindert werden
diese plenarsaal zu betreten
aber wie gesagt die haben ja gerade auch
schon einen etwas besseren blick auf die
türen werfen können da ist niemand mehr
zu betreten ich bitte also die
schriftführerin und schriftführer das
ergebnis festzustellen die abstimmung
über die ausschuss überweisung und
gleichzeitig die feststellung inwieweit
der deutsche bundestag
[Musik]
inwieweit der deutsche bundestag
beschlussfähig ist werden wir jetzt
gleich feststellen
schließen sie bitte die türen dorthin
[Applaus]
jetzt müsste das ergebnis dieser
abstimmung dieses hammelsprung es bei
der bundestags- vizepräsidentin
angekommen sein
sie hat das blatt wenden wir uns nicht
völlig vergucken bereits in der hand
ich gebe ihnen das ergebnis der
abstimmung bekannt
abgegebene stimmen 414
[Applaus]
dadurch
so ich bitte die ordnung und die
aufmerksamkeit herzustellen
das muss man vielleicht mal ganz schnell
mit einem satz erklären diese berufe die
hieraus der mehrheit des hauses gekommen
sind denn jetzt nachdem die
abschließende abstimmung geschlossen ist
und das ergebnis verkündet wird jetzt
kommen auch die afg abgeordneten wieder
rein also haben sich eine abstimmung die
sie selber verlangt haben entzogen und
kommt jetzt zurück in den plenarsaal
das abstimmungsergebnis noch gar nicht
vollständig bekannt gegeben
also der vollständigkeit halber
abgegeben wurden 414 stimmen mit ja
haben 413 abgeordnete gestimmt und es
gab eine enthaltung
damit
jetzt erheben sich die abgeordneten in
den hinteren reihen zumindest schon mal
aber das setzt sich jetzt vor ort jetzt
erheben sich das habe ich auch noch
nicht erlebt hier im deutschen bundestag
jetzt erheben sich die abgeordneten aus
der unionsfraktion aus der spd den
grünen linksfraktion und auch fdp von
ihren sitzen stehen auf und applaudieren
sich quasi selbst wenn man das so deuten
will für dieses abstimmungsergebnis das
btv eben vorgetragen hat und ist
gleichzeitig ein deutlicher einer ganz
eindeutige kritik auch an der afg
fraktion die hier eine abstimmung
beantragt hat und an dieser abstimmung
anschließend gar nicht erst teilgenommen
hat und diese abstimmung im grunde auch
verloren hat wenn man so will denn
beschlussfähig ist der bundestag ganz
eindeutig 6426 24 sind offensichtlich
mit großer begeisterung des gesamten
hauses überwiesen worden
[Applaus]